[Music]
we're here in the customer magic
neighborhood with kind of a pretty
impressive booth here with NASA and
James the director of NASA FDA yeah I am
I'm the NASA FTL is an applied AI
research lab for NASA
it's a public-private partnership which
is great so it means we cannot ask
corporate partners or experts may either
help us with our problems so with that
in mind yeah how does Google Cloud and
NASA FTL work together well we had a big
problem and the problem was are we alone
which is kind of the big one and we knew
that you liked big problems so we
thought well hey we'll call it Google
and see if they can help us what's
interesting about this problem is we
have scientists who are fantastic at
understanding the problem and enormous
data like data you can't imagine how big
it is huge and and so really we needed a
corporate expert like they're like
Google to help us what we've prototypes
was going about with FTL is the sort of
relationships and sort of partnerships
which NASA is going to need if we
people in the moon at five years so it's
really I feel like we kind of turned the
water about how the future should be
just in terms of you know the way we're
solving problems the way we're
partnering you know that's that's what
we're weaving prototype of a few guys
that's really you know what Google is so
amazing at and I have to say thank you
for the help you guys have given because
we did it we've done some really
extraordinary work here and I think
NASA's gonna take us through some of the
some of the fragments of what was done
and this is what you can come and see at
this this booth we're very proud of the
work and just like to say thanks again
oh of course I mean it's great to hear
it's it's super exciting to see this
kind of really turn to what can we
actually do with this technology how do
we help people and so we're gonna walk
through and see what people hear it next
can kind of get their hands on and
experiment with and then also see how
does that help us answer are we alone
yeah the team we've done a great job of
taking something really complex and make
it really simple and you can have a go
and you know play with your like curbs
and finding exoplanets so
there's some really cool stuff to get
your hands on here as well awesome let's
take a look yeah so we just talked to
James about how the partnership between
NASA FTL and Google cloud helped the
naval scientists to really start doing
this analysis what can people here at
next actually play with to see what that
looks like yeah absolutely so the the
challenge was Grundy right finding life
on other planets so how do you break it
down in steps so step one you have to
find other planets that are outside the
solar system right so we actually worked
on that challenge to start with and what
you can see here is a little bit of a
representation of how that works so the
way we have one of these light curves
and the task here you can do is actually
try to kind of classify by eyes there's
a planet or not so as you can see
actually said it's a quite hard task you
know like you have to kind of understand
when things are planet or not and
they're actually a lot of like
subtleties here this takes actually a
lot of human labour and a lot of like
astrophysics mines actually spent on
this for years
so what we had as an idea is that can
actually have machine learning help us
with this and so we use actually the
power of like deep learning and AI in
Google cloud to kind of train a model
that does this so the researchers did
this actually with our technology and
actually they were able to get a model
that is not only more accurate than
humans it can actually kind of process
entire datasets in minutes where before
she took years so people can kind of see
the details of why it was so important
to have machine learning help out the
human knowledge that was required to
make this happen
absolutely so for those exoplanets can
we take a look at those and the mobile
apps over there yeah so like here we
have a very simple app that you can use
to kind of scan the sky and there are a
lot of like planets in the sky and once
you point at one of those planets you
can actually kind of study it and you
would get the composition of the
atmosphere of that planet and so this
actually is more kind of a gamified
version of this that represents why is
this so important so this is like a cool
way to see and kind of get a little bit
of a taste into exactly what goes into
making those decisions and understanding
all the technology that's required to
say look we're now making these
predictions let's see if we can find
somewhere and actually
answer is there life out there
absolutely and again I mean like the the
beauty of this is that a lot of this
work has been done by astrophysicists
and you know kind of astronomy
researchers that didn't have a lot of
like IT knowledge or AI knowledge they
were just act hour by both the power of
computation in Google cloud and by our
AI tools kind of answered this really
really hard questions right it lets them
focus on what's important to them and
the technology just helps enable it
absolutely that's awesome thanks so much
thank you
[Music]
you